foreign
[Music]
if a ship was to capsize they don't just
turn Turtle quickly they fill up with
water and for the vessel to turn that
quickly so that people would have to
hang on to things uh not believable hi
I'm captain Wendy Williams recently I
was the first Canadian woman to Captain
a mega cruise ship today we'll be
looking at cruise ship disasters in
movies and TV and deciding how realistic
they are
disaster is the one that everybody
Associates with Marine disasters first
of all it struck an iceberg I'm hoping
it would never happen again but I don't
I never say it will never happen again
we just have a lot more technology and
we have
associations and the ability to track
some of the bigger icebergs now I don't
think that
the crew of the Titanic were even
expecting ice whereas now it's part of
the training
with any incidents on board there's
checklists to things but there are
initial actions for uh for something
that may involve striking or grounding
or hitting another vessel and that is to
close all the watertight doors what they
called watertight compartments were not
actually water tight so they actually
put doors through what should have been
watertight compartments and what
happened was that the vessel
progressively flooded
if a ship were to have a strike there
may be the need to um to be in a in a
water filled or water filling area and
have to do exactly what Jack and Rose
did Unfortunately they got to the top of
the stairs and things were locked that
doesn't happen there are emergency
escapes that everybody is trained for
you have to hold an emergency drill
is it advisable to go up or down
I mean the ship is sinking you're going
to do what you're going to do the
freight or flight kicks in
and we would be just grappling to find
the highest point before uh succumbing
to having to be in the water some people
actually in the in a situation where the
ship is not actually sinking they choose
that jumping into the water is the
safest method
um my view and what I tell everybody and
when we're going through training is you
know your ship is your biggest Lifeboat
you don't want to be in one of those
little boats unless you absolutely have
to in this case a lot of people died
because they could not be uh they could
not safely get off the vessel I think
it's like an eight it was really well
done and I would imagine that it was a
very similar to to that event
I've seen the movie that's food illness
I've never been on a ship where there's
been an issue with food the food and the
food preparation it's very highly
regulated everybody has to have special
food preparation courses I'm sure it
does happen it just isn't a cause for
alarm cruise ships have been in the news
a lot for something called norovirus
typically the cruise ship does not have
norovirus on it people bring norovirus
to the ship
for tonight thank you for tonight thank
you sisters is a guy bringing out an AED
that just happens to have one crew
members would even though they're
trained they would just be making people
comfortable they wouldn't actually be
doing solo medical procedures on a
vessel of that size there would be a
dedicated medical crew typically they
would carry a doctor and a nurse and
have some sort of triage place
thank you
piracy is a thing there is there are
pirate attacks of many different types
of vessels in the world cruise ships are
not
um not exempt from that I mean there's
all different shapes and sizes of how
vessels do navigate through areas where
there is a risk of piracy there are
agencies that actually put people on
board with weapons there's like barbed
wire on Deck charged fire hoses it's it
it can get pretty nasty the Pirates
themselves some of them are equipped
with things like rocket launchers and
really bad Weaponry that can do a lot of
damage I'm assuming the explosion at the
stern of the vessel here happened
because of one grenade I don't think
grenade would be able to take down a
vessel of that side of one of them
believability here
probably four or five for how the
situations were being handled and the
actual attack itself
that's impossible radios uh there are so
many backups and if the radios didn't
work you have satellite phones all sorts
of different types of satellite
communication to be able to scramble a
ship like that
uh no
what's happening here
there's a lot of people on the bridge
I'm not sure what they're all doing most
Cruise companies not seeing all of them
they have different terminology but we
would have what's called green yellow
and red conditions green would be when
everything is smooth sailing typically
you would have you would have a
navigation officer up there you would
have an assistant or a co-navigator and
you would have one or two Lookouts that
would be the bridge composition our
bridges uh like a full
red condition would be Captain staff
captain Chief mate or Communicator two
Lookouts that's it five five of you on
the bridge handling the situation we
just plot of whales moving at 31 knots
sir I don't think so where is it coming
from directly beneath
this particular cruise ship is equipped
with sonar which I don't know why you
would even need that you wouldn't so
everything is is scrambled except for
the sonar that's picking up some I guess
it's a sea monster in this one even
though in this particular movie clip
um they're dealing with a with a sea
monster not to put whales or large
mammals into a category of being sea
monsters very unfortunately there are
whale strikes cruise ships pay a lot of
attention to uh give a a large leave
distance and to avoid whales at all
costs believability from that bridge
scene probably zero
this one looked like Niagara Falls on
its side not a believable wave a tsunami
is biggest when it kind of hits the
shore
out at Sea a tsunami might just be a
wave like any other wave so the fact
that this is a tsunami and not a rogue
wave yeah probably not that believable
being that a tsunami wave wouldn't look
like that you wouldn't necessarily
navigate away from the actual wave but
you would you would navigate away from
the area of concern if you could
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I do remember seeing this as a kid I
remember the dining room scene and
everything going upside down our tables
and chairs and pianos and things secured
cruise ships larger vessels they have
something called a heavy weather or a
heavy object register list and yes a
larger or Big Ticket items that can
cause a lot of damage like a piano could
literally go through a wall a bulkhead
so they are secured tables and chairs no
they would be movable and for the vessel
to turn that quickly so that people
would have to hang on to things uh not
believable if a ship was to capsize they
don't just turn Turtle quickly they fill
up with water
all right now what we're in shaft alley
nowhere is a steel hole thinner
this Hull is only one inch thick would
there be a sustained amount of time that
people could have survived inside there
I mean
possibly yes there would be air pockets
the likelihood of there being that much
air that much time highly unlikely the
shaft alley that's interesting because
the shell plating thickness is only one
inch that is probably Icebreaker class
one inch would be exceptionally thick
ship hulls are not that not that thick
typically but in engine spaces technical
spaces they would be thickness varies
depending on how the ship is built and
for what class probably give it a nine
as far as fun movies go believability
two three the deadly Pandora virus is
spreading rapidly unprecedented threat
requires a worldwide quarantine
given that it was created in 2012 the
pandemic took Everyone by surprise and
certainly cruise ships that were already
in mid Crews suddenly were getting cases
of of the virus on board the Diamond
Princess was very unfortunate that she
had a lot of cases on board and then was
put under quarantine she was kind of
like the worst case scenario ships are
now being constructed with ventilation
such that it's independent in cabins
filtration systems much like the airline
industry did
as we greet a sunny day 12 after virus
today's delicious Buffet features fresh
seagull and Hull scraped Barnacles would
the ship look like that after 12 days no
but in The Simpsons world that's
absolutely perfect vessels could only be
out at sea for as long as their fuel and
food supply would allow them to be we
didn't and we wouldn't keep people past
that point cruise ships do carry a lot
of food and they carry food in excess of
of what the voyage length would be but
not by that much so I'd probably give
that a nine just because it's actually
pretty spot on for having been made
almost a decade before our pandemic
juice
they're in a ship's jail or a Brig ours
look a lot different than that you
wouldn't be thrown in there with others
they're holding cells and they are
typically a cabin without furniture with
a mattress on the ground and they're
under camera surveillance and they have
a window non-break window in a door
typically they're not in there for very
long it could be just the night before
we get to Port but there's a lot of
factors before we could actually put
somebody in in a kind of time out
whatever the situation is it's to
mitigate anybody else getting hurt from
their actions or from them harming
themselves this is a big cruise ship
it's got like a big deep sound it's like
yeah if you're starting the engine but
like we would be hearing a steady
the guy that was doing the kind of like
the low the low boom boom boom is
probably closest it depends what kind of
propulsion they have so if they have a
big a big diesel big diesel engines
working you may have that that guy that
was generating that boom boom boom sound
it's almost a comforting sound I feel I
find it comforting
you wouldn't be left alone
that was a little unrealistic it's kind
of a Common Thread here everything on a
cruise ship uh these it's done with
checklists so that we we don't forget
people we don't forget to sweep areas it
would be part of the security team's
protocol to escort them to A muster area
that would not happen the believability
of the jail scene not not believable
this is dealing with the Rogue Wave for
a long time people didn't even believe
that rogue waves actually existed it's
an anomaly wave that is different from
all of the other waves in a certain sea
State and then it could you know
overturn vessels or come at vessels
basically the tip or the bow has what's
called a collision bulkhead and it's
very strong construction you never
really want to take anything broadside
because even in a small sea a vessel can
get into what's called synchronous
synchronicity which will cause it to
become very unstable
the announcements were not appropriate I
I felt that they caused panic and as a
captain you want everybody to know
what's happening but there are ways to
word things to make people feel
like their understanding of the
situation this is what's happening but I
am in the hands of a very trained crew
and if I follow instruction I will be
safe and you would have crew members
whose Duty it would be to do crowd
control
fantastic stability criteria they call
it and it would take a lot to capsize
one of these is it going to happen as a
result of a you know the general rogue
waves that I've read about not not
really now if a cruise ship were to go
off vertical these areas that are not
watertight would fill fill with water
causing the capsize a good example of
that we may have seen that maybe people
will understand is that Costa Concordia
she went over and she would have kept
going over were it not for the depth of
water that she was in
that's a little bit of a movie thing
you're not going to really get
explosions because explosions would have
to do with vapors Catching Fire somehow
or igniting and a large amount of vapors
in an area causing these random
explosions and on cruise ships you just
don't have that in the accommodation I
can't think of something that would
cause those Fireballs although exciting
very exciting believability of what was
going on probably a five four
somewhere in that room but fun fun to
watch
ready
now for somebody to be able to control
the main engines of a vessel no you
they're not they're not hooked into an
automation system that anybody would be
able to take over there's automated
systems on board but everything can be
done manually
you want to flood the ship
there aren't ballast doors there's
watertight doors and there's ballast
tanks those are the tanks that you can
fill with water to change the trim of a
vessel someone's just taking the wrong
turn and put it with the wrong equipment
foreign have to have been going at a
very very fast rate for it to sort of
glance off like that but the amount of
speed uh and the two vessels would have
been fairly crumpled there was a few
black marks along the side not even a
crumpled bow that yeah not really
believable for the cargo vessel to have
an anchor just swinging loose that
wouldn't happen angles anchors are
either stowed or they're diploid the
cargo vessel was not moving and there
was no C to make the anchor swing those
things where it weigh like tons and tons
livability on a scale of to ten maybe
three two not a lot their meat on the
bones for an actual incident my favorite
cruise ship scene from today would have
to be Titanic it's the basis for all the
safety protocol that we we do today and
I think the portrayal of what was
happening the severity of the situation
was was very readily understood if you
have enjoyed this today all you have to
do is click the link above and set sail
for another one
foreign